so you may be asking yourself what
exactly
is fall guys oh everybody's
everybody's trying you gotta get all the
yellow block
what what is fall guys
well it's a new battle royale from
devolver digital
but it's unlike any battle royale i've
ever seen
what is happening why am i going
backwards 22 i've already qualified what
no jump no we were right there at the
finish line
no no no no you start with 60 players
and you are trying to be the last one to
survive so that much
that part is similar to battle royale as
long as you move on it's like march
madness we didn't get a march madness
this year
survive and advance though that's the
motto the way i described it was like
most extreme elimination challenge if
you remember that old show
this is now
american gladiators you know ladies and
gentlemen
we're gonna go ahead and get started
here let me switch over to the game
first time ever we've got to be in the
top 44.
i'm assuming it's x to jump yeah it is
and then uh square will like do the
little oh no
no no no no no no not like this not like
this
okay see we got we got to work together
guys we got to work together come on
let's work together
nice is anybody qualified yet
okay see this is i've i've been watching
streams all day and i have not seen this
one
we got to work together yes come on get
it go the other way
actually me and you buddy you know what
we can we can go on just like this
yep yep yep oh we're moving now
we're moving now chat no no no come on
let's work together
no no no chat guys it's not gonna work
oh man oh no tin
okay i think we're so good i think we're
still good look at this dude man look at
this dude just trying to push people
back
american ninja warrior b del pont yes
oh no not this look at these little
rollers
no no
ha ha all right okay see now we're gonna
be able to use this to our advantage
here i think
nope not that not what i meant to do all
right you know what i'm playing this
outside game
i'm playing the outside game again okay
i don't understand that
i don't understand i should have been
perfectly in line
i don't feel like you're penalized too
much though when you get pushed down
right there
yeah let's help each other guys let's
help each other just keep pushing them
we gotta use our combined strength
hey let the mint chocolate through come
on
oh my goodness look at this log jam
stay over here stay over here
watch it zero out of 44 if qualified oh
my goodness already qualifying 12.
we're not gonna qualify we are not gonna
qualify in the very first one
yes just barely oh that's my teammate
again dude i can't take it from my
teammate
oh yeah one no he stole it he stole it
the blue guy stole it right after
right after we took it
come here green guy yes i'm on your team
do not take it from your teammate
do not take it from your teammate okay
okay okay okay we're good chat we're
good
no no no don't you dare little blue man
little blue man
oh here's this here's this green guy
over here let's wait for the screen guy
look at him look at him he doesn't know
what's coming for him chat
you're on my team yellow guy i'm telling
you dude
do not take it 20 seconds
is this the play chat is this the play
all right let's hang out with my yellow
guy friend over here
oh yeah dude we're just hanging out
we're just hanging out boom
oh here comes that green guy again no no
no jump off the edge yes yes
five seconds
oh he wasn't even close to me
i still qualified i still qualified
why'd i still qualify chad did he not
get in time
clearly this is not our game chat this
this this little mini game right here is
not a good one for us
i still don't know why i got sent back a
second ago
when i didn't even get hit by a fruit
already five of 18 qualified
i don't think jumping is wise like when
i started jumping it was it was worse
for me yeah
13 14 15. you know what we got a chance
we got a chance
moving on baby yes indeed got my
okay we're just gonna pretend that
didn't happen all right if they're if
they're new to this though they're gonna
mess up on this one i guarantee you
yeah see like like i'm just i'm just
showing you guys
i'm just showing you guys what what
inexperienced players would do on this
one right here
see you gotta work together you gotta
work together with the folks
on the seesaw this is one of my favorite
ones so far actually
i love that you have to work together
and kind of coordinate even though
you're competing against them at the
same time
oh yeah we're good for this one right
[Music]
here
whoa what a dive i'm heading left
we got a nice clear path right here
can i fit through that i'm tempted to
test it but
al nobody's qualified yet
hold on it's about to come around let's
wait for it be patient be patient
be patient
i've learned from no no
that's what i get for acting like i have
any idea what i'm actually doing you
guys
i'm going the first one from the right
over here guys
i'm taking a guess we're diving in let's
go
taking another guess oh okay never mind
i'm following you guys you're already
through
taking a guess right here taking a guess
right here yes
dude three for three on the guesses
right now it's gonna be back right here
now okay nope
three for four on the guesses not bad
this guy knows what he's doing though
yes i'm going all in on this one
no denied we're gonna get caught right
here
no only the middle one only the middle
one
huge funnel huge log jam where did all
those players come from
we just need to be in the top 44 that's
all that matters
staying to the right lane over here that
was a lot closer than i thought it was
going to be
only 15 qualify oh
it was too late to move so i was like
please watermelon just go over my head 3
out of 15 qualify
still looking okay there we go there we
go there we go
look at that wolf dude that wolf is
playing ruthless
all right that wolf those wolves are bad
news over there man
i am staying away from the wolves like
they were they were trying to mess with
people at the finish line on the last
one
oh yeah we're good right here so i don't
want to get too close to the edge yeah
cause see look at that they're trying to
grab you and just shove you off
ain't nobody got time for that we need
14 people eliminated
i feel like like kind of trying to stay
middle in the middle of a group here
you don't really want to get too far
near the edge
because those are the people that get
targeted
we'll see like here i'm on the outside
i'm on the edge that wolf was coming
after me
oh oh we got to jump now guys
oh no i messed up trying to grab him
oh no no no get up why wouldn't
it wouldn't let me jump okay this one
let's see if they got the memo
no no no guys come on work together
i shouldn't have jumped oh i don't think
i should go yet i don't think i should
go yet
yeah the wolf's being smart too if you
get this game this game right here guys
like this
this mini game don't think you're done
because
it's very easy to catch up in this one
all right so we need to get top 45
stay over here look at that look at that
see you just gotta trust in your timing
just trust in your timing chat trust in
it trust in it we're good right here
all day baby all day
are we in first right now don't tell
anybody
i'm waiting right here yes
oh this one's gonna be difficult to time
i don't like it i need to stop and jump
hey second place all right you know what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna go straight for
this
i'm just gonna try to keep it in here i
feel like that
honestly i feel like that may be the
biggest key is playing defense early
[Music]
we just need to defend oh i got it back
at first but then he
can i grab hold of it sorry we just need
three we just need three we just need
three we just need three
let's go moving on baby
can i just hide right here oh no he sees
me but he has a tail
i don't like this chat they're getting a
little too close to me
this pink guy needs to back off
get someone else's tail you
that what he wasn't even close to me
so two hours worth i'm still having a
blast with it haven't won any games yet
i think our best was around top five
so far okay that one if you get this
level guys remember that you got a jump
right there
it's a little bit deceiving
oh look at him he was trying to die for
the finish line i respect it i respect
it
you gotta make it to the top and grab
the crown this is this is it chad this
is for
all the marbles can we get that sweet
sweet victory we gotta grab the crown
i've got a plan here that i'm gonna use
see i think everybody's gonna go for the
middle yeah
i'm going straight for the edge right
here i'm chilling dude i'm chilling over
here by myself
look at that look at that not even
worried about these obstacles
now i'm gonna slide over here because
you know what i'm gonna use this right
here to kind of propel me forward
dude those guys in the middle though i
think i think they went a lot faster
it's not over yet though it's not over
it may be over now
yeah sometimes you can use the the
little barriers to actually help you
oh that guy's gonna win that wolf up
there is gonna win oh
and then there was another guy we were
probably like what third now there was
there were two on the left
so we would have probably been about
fourth or fifth right there you are
watching retroreckons we're live this is
a family-friendly stream we do this
thing every monday
wednesday and sometimes fridays thanks
so much for stopping by
and i'll talk to you guys again soon